early in 2013 the band day above-ground
made a brief impact in the cultural
sphere with their song Asian girls in
its accompanying music video the song is
jaw-droppingly racist creamy and fast ah
this is of course the only reason why
anyone gave a rat's ass because even
levy Tran prancing around in her
underpants isn't enough to make anyone
care about a band as forgettable as day
above ground I mean the Internet has
plenty of photos of MS Tran in various
states of undress if I want to see them
I don't need to couple the experience
with watching these guys swim up her
vagina
so yes the racism is the main reason
anyone noticed it's also sexist in
equally ridiculous if less extreme way
really you could go through this line by
line every bit of it is some level of
offensive either in its implications or
direct construction like that intro that
riff called the oriental riff is an
American leitmotif written in 1847 for
musical about Aladdin it doesn't
actually have anything to do with Asia
in the sense that it's not actually from
anywhere in Asia it's just what white
people imagine Asian music sounds like
nowhere specifically in Asia just you
know vaguely Asian and in that sense
it's a really good summary of the song
as a whole the entire song is really
just a mashup of indistinct stereotypes
lumping all Asian cultures together spun
up with sexual innuendo and interspersed
with some really weird lines I love you
stick you love it but [ __ ] on
I don't even know how to parse that Oh
their bassist Indonesian himself is
dressed up like a math geek because you
know they're not racist
they've got Asian friends and Asians are
good at map yeah naturally a lot of
people didn't take too well to the song
especially since it contains lines like
the following
come here baby yeah you know that kind
of there's this thing that's a big
problem especially in Asia called human
trafficking specifically sex trafficking
so you know I don't think it really
matters what direction you were trying
to go with your little Orientalist sex
ballad maybe extorting sex with the
threat of deportation isn't really a
wise choice I mean that's a thing that
happens like this happens in real life
women boys girls people usually living
in poverty are lured into sexual slavery
and wealthier nations where they're
robbed of their documentation and
discouraged from escaping or seeking
help with threats of deportation or
violence against them and/or their
family back home
not exactly a subject known to make the
panties drop understandably the band
received pretty much immediate backlash
their response is a nice little
encapsulation of what has become the
default public relations crisis response
in recent years and that's what we're
going to focus on here the revisionist
narrative for the record though I didn't
think to get a screenshot at the time
the original video description called it
an ode to some of the most beautiful
women on earth first they took the video
down then re uploaded it a couple days
later with a new description saying that
everyone was just getting bent out of
shape over nothing taking the whole
thing too seriously and that it was all
in good fun a few days later the video
was taken down yet again and eventually
re re uploaded with another new
description saying it was being taken
out of context that the song and video
were intended to be satirical
observations a few weeks later the video
was taken down for good from their
official channel though it's still
widely available through unofficial
uploads their response to the media was
much the same first insisting the people
were being too stuffy then claiming the
whole thing was a satire but a satire of
what well a satire of themselves
nothing in this arc particularly
surprised me mostly because this has
become a common and predictable response
in recent time if you go too far just
claim it was all a joke
also it didn't really surprise me
because the whole time I was watching it
felt like I was seeing a lost skit from
the boondocks or frisky dingo okay so if
it feels like something belongs in a
satire maybe they're right
well no because it still doesn't pass
the sniffed test if it's sincere it's
repugnant if it's satire it's a failure
just because you tried to make a satire
doesn't mean you succeeded in fact the
hazard of satire is that failure doesn't
simply result in an unfunny joke satire
is more than just comedy satire has a
message an agenda it's criticism as a
form of criticism it involves taking on
the voice of the thing that you are
criticizing and then elevating it to
absurd extremes if you fail you've
counter productively created an extreme
version of whatever you were attempting
to satire this is ultimately the root of
Poe's law without a blatant display of
humor it is impossible to create a
parody of extremism or fundamentalism
that someone won't mistake for the real
thing
so giving day above ground the
undeserved mind.you
benefit of the doubt let me assume Asian
girls is intended to be satire under
that assumption how does it fail
broadly speaking it fails due to a lack
of framing there's no grounding point no
sense of how we're supposed to be
viewing the material and what we're
supposed to think about it or well there
are those things but they're not pointed
towards satire ostensibly the song and
video are a satire of white men who
fetishize Asian women but that voice the
fetishization is the only one present
it's present in the lyrics it's present
in the story and it is very present in
the cinematography actually brief
interlude the story of the music video
is that levy Tran is a woman who seeks
out men that fetishize her for being
Asian feeds them a shrinking potion
keeps them captive to worship her as
their goddess and uses them for her
voyeuristic and sexual gratification
none of them are remotely opposed to
this relationship that right there is
the crux of the framing problem no one
ever objects the men never have a moment
where they realize they're idiots or are
served their comeuppance and there's no
third party raising an eyebrow as I said
earlier I felt like I was watching a bit
from the boondocks or frisky dingo
but without Huey or kill face to act as
an audience surrogate by expressing our
shared displeasure and condemnation in
practice quite the opposite happens the
song has a roll call name dropping large
Asian communities in California and
showing groups of Asian women
participating in the call-out the
narrative purpose of this is to show
solidarity to normalize the narrative
it's functionally the same as saying I
have a friend who is blank and they
found it funny to dismiss criticism as a
whole the story surrounding Asian girls
is I think a positive one a band
told a tactless unfunny joke and
everyone called them on it the problem I
have with this revision is narrative
though is that it always passes through
an accusative phase and never really
settles on any sense of ownership the
accusative phases the part where they
make it your fault for being offended
your fault for not getting their humor
or missing the point it's essentially
throwing a childish tantrum to avoid
facing the fact that you know maybe you
just screwed up the delivery or maybe
the joke just wasn't that funny to begin
with and you know what I'm willing to
give day above-ground some credit I can
totally buy the idea that when they were
writing this as a closed
of friends they thought it was hilarious
that it's a giant in joke that they all
got that a lot of the worst parts just
kind of spun out of a dough headed
feeling of permissibility that stems
from the safety of being a white male in
america or that the higher level satire
mocking the entitled attitude just
didn't make it all the way through the
process that's fine i don't think there
was any malice here just you know own it
don't call it satire and blame the
audience for not getting it call it an
in-joke that just didn't work for a
wider audience
you